you have to learn how to advertise and
then once people engage with whatever
advertisement you have you have to sell
them so advertising is the first skill
selling them is the second skill product
would be the third skill which is the
thing that you're ultimately advertising
and selling okay so that gets us six
figures what gets a seven doing the same
thing consistently so usually once
people do it in the beginning they're
sporadic they're not consistent with it
just the act of doing the same thing
every day usually gets people to 100 000
a month which sounds crazy it's probably
people listening but most people who
think that's crazy also haven't done it
consistently for an extended period of
time and so I use something that I call
the rule 100 100 minutes of content
creation per day 100 reach outs per day
100 of AD spend per day you have to pick
one of them but 100 per day you do that
for 100 days and I promise you'll be
making six figures if you do